parts of Virginia also have more than a
foot and a half of snow the storm
paralyzed major interstates and left
drivers stranded overnight more than 100
accidents were reported statewide Errol
Barnett is in Chesterfield Virginia
south of Richmond tracking the efforts
of 4,600 trucks they need to clear
around 13,000 miles of roads what a job
Errol good morning good morning take a
look at this it's just one example of
what round the round the-clock work
looks like all of these snow plow
drivers are pulling 12-hour shifts
coming here to refuel and reload on a
salt sand mix which is stored in that
dome way in the distance but despite
this gargantuan effort some of the roads
here may not be usable until Wednesday
take a look at this up in Richmond to
snow and ice sent drivers sliding off
the highway we saw this as we drove in
at least 1,000 stalled cars have been
reported and down trees trapped some
drivers along i-85 overnight in Bristol
motorists who were stranded for more
than 12 hours had to be rescued by the
Virginia National Guard this is on I 81
emergency crews had to get out and walk
to access those with medical emergencies
and people riding ATVs brought folks
water bottles as they waited in the snow
but it is not over yet temperatures are
expected to dip below freezing rain is
expected tonight which means that iced
over roads will continue to be a hazard
and in addition to all of that some
coastal areas of Virginia are facing
multiple storm and flood warnings and
watches with some coastal areas
expecting 8-foot waves beyond us not
over yet air will stay warm with that
other glove on too please